[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
نحن هنا في البيت السعودي الذي يعد ملتقى
مشجعين منتخب السعودي من كافه الجنسيات
البيت السعودي مقر مشجعي الاخضر في الدوحه
ومركز لنقل الثقافه السعوديه لضيوف
المونديال
الله
احتفالات على وقع الخساره العاب الناريه
واهازيج في المدن الايرانيه بعد هزيمه
منتخبهم امام الولايات المتحده
العسكريه
نحو البحر الاسود
اختراق علمي دواء جديد لمرضى الالفايمر
يمنح املا بامكانيه علاج المصابين والقضاء
على المرض
[موسيقى]
بعد ساعه من الان تبدا مواجهه ساخنه بين
المنتخبين السعودي والمكسيكي بالتوازي مع
مواجهه لا تقل سخونه بين الارجنتين
وبولاندا حظوظ المنتخبات الاربعه متساويه
في تاهل للدوري القادم وان كانت المكسيك
اقل حظا من البقيه ثلاثه نقاط اخرى يقاتل
الاخضر اليوم للحصول عليها ليضمن بها
التاهل وخلف الاخضر ملايين العيون المسمر
على شاشات في المنازل والمقاهي وداخل
الملعب تتمنى تاهل اولى المنتخبات العربيه
للدور ال 16 في الدوحه البيت السعودي جاهز
لمباراه العمره وكالعاده العربيه اول
الحاضرين مع الزميل ليس بازاريا المتابعه
نحن هنا في البيت السعودي الذي يعد ملتقى
مشجعين منتخب السعودي من كافه الجنسيات
يعد هذا المكان الذي يمتد على مساحه 18
الف متر مكان لقاء المشجعين فالكثير منهم
يقصده قبل الانطلاق الى الملاعب التي
يواجه فيها المنتخب خصومه الهدف من هذا
المكان هو اثراء تجربه المشجعين السعوديين
في مونديال قطر 2022 والتعريف الثقافه
السعوديه اذا يستمتع الزوار بتجربه لاعب
كره القدم مع كبار اللاعبين افتراديا في
جناح الاحلام عبر تقنيه الواقع المعزز
والواقع الافتراضي اضافه الى تجربه
التصوير مع تشكيله المنتخب السعودي
افتراضيه
ويستطيع الشغل بكره القدم متابعه مباريات
المونديال عبر شاشه عرض ضخمه الى جانب
مساحه خضراء تتسع لاعاده كبير من مشجع
المنتخب السعودي الذي سيواجه المنتخب
المكسيكي اليوم ليلا في ملعب لوسيل هنا في
الدوحه كما تحتل الاكلات السعوديه قوائم
الماكولات التي تمكن ضيوف البيت السعودي
من تناولها كما يتسوق المشجعون من متجر
الصقور الخضر الذي [__] على زي المنتخب
الرسمي بالاضافه الى اعلام وشعارات
المنتخب السعودي
العربيه الدوحه دوله قطر
مجددا الى زميل ليث بازاري كيف هي الاجواء
لديك ليث قبيله انطلاقات المباراه بين
المنتخب السعودي والمكسيك
[موسيقى]
يعني باستمرار بارتفاع درجه الحراره هنا
وتكلم هنا على المشجعين الجميع هنا على
اهبه الاستعداد لانتظار بيت المباراه بعد
اقل من ساعه من الان في لوسيل الملعب الذي
يقع جنوب مدينه الدوحه ولكن هنا الهدفافات
لا تتوقف العب العب العب هز شمال الملعب
وخلي الخصر يتعب يا سعودي
[موسيقى]
صلى الله علينا اوه هيه هيه هيه
ي الاجواء يعني اذا دخلنا الكاميرا
بالمناطق الثانيه سوف نلاحظ كم هي اعداد
المشجعين الذين وصلوا الى هناك البيت
السعودي وما زالت الاعداد اخرى تصل من هم
من هم من وصل على الاقدام وفي السياره
والحافلات والبعض الاخر جاء جولا شاهدنا
في سماء هذه المنطقه الطيران السعودي وهو
يحط ويذهب اتجاه همم مطار حمد لوصول اعداد
جديده وكثيفه من
المتشجعين السعوديون الذين يصلون هنا الى
الدوحه ويتجهون الكثير منهم مباشره الى
لوسيل اذا يملك تذاكر يتجه الى محيط السيل
او الى هنا كما تشاهدين الكثير من العرب
كذلك يوجد شفنا جنسيه همم تونسيه قبل قليل
وجزائريه وفلسطينيين ولبنانيين واردنيين
ومغاربه وكذلك يعني شاهدنا عند اقل من
ساعه من الان عندما انتهت المباراه بين
ااا تونس وفرنسا كيف كان الجمهور متوحد
الجمهور الجمهور العربي هنا في الدوحه في
البيت السعودي كان متوحد وكان ينظر الى
الى كان ينظر كان يشهد يعني
يرصد المباراه نقطه بنقطه لحظه بلحظه حتى
يعني بانتظار فوز تونس المنتخب التونسي
وهذا ما حصل وكان طبعا افواج
المجموعات الموجوده هنا من الشباب
التونسيين والسعوديين يقومون بالتصفيق
بحراره
والحديث وتحرير المباريات او المباراه
التي شهدت على الهواء مباشره قبل قليل
وهذه يعني الاجواء وطبعا راح يكون معكم
اكيد نشات همم
لاحقه بعد ساعه من الان اتوقع او في نهايه
هذه النشره اذا امكن حتى ما يحصل هنا يعني
الفن والرياضه والثقافه كما تشاهدين هناك
من يقومون بالعاب وهناك لا سمعنا قبل قليل
اغاني لطلال مداح واا طلال سلامه كذلك
ورابح صقر وغيرها وراشد الماجد وهمم يعني
والتي كانت تغني في هذه المنطقه تفضل
حبيبي
[موسيقى]
كبيره المنتخب طيب اكيد راح ساعه يعني راح
يكون موجود في البيت السعودي لمتابعه
المهرجان ولا راح تروح على استاذ معك ساعه
تروح همم يعني راح تشجع على المنتخب من
هنا من البيت السعودي ولا راح تروح على
العطار ان شاء الله نروح نشجع هنا المره
القادمه ان شاء الله في النهائي ان شاء
الله
السلام عليكم
من كم سيكون العدد كم ستفوز السعوديه في
هذا البرنامج في هذه المباراه
ليس فقط في المباريات الذين التي يشاهد
يشاهدون هنا على هذه الشاشه الضخمه همم
على هذه الشاشه الضخمه بل ايضا يقومون
بالحديد ما بينهم يوجد من قطر
لا يوجد شباب من السعوديه من اي منطقه
انتم جايين انا من الاردن جاي يصلي 20 يوم
وانا اوكي عشان احضر المونديال ان شاء
الله اثنين واحد السعوديه
اوه
ايش اسمها
الاعداد
المتخرجين والاحتفالات ان شاء الله
يوم ولا يومين ولا ثلاثه اتحاد السعوديه
راح يكون معكم مباشر طول الليل هاي وعد
مني وان شاء الله راح البحر ان شاء الله
ليث سنعود اليك بعد قليل خلال سياق
التاسعه
لمواكبه انطلاق المباراه بين المنتخب
السعودي
والمكسيك ونقل الاجواء الحماسيه من الدوحه
شكرا لك يا ليث
[موسيقى]
ان تفرح لخساره خصمك هذا امر طبيعي ويحصل
في الرياضه والسياسه ايضا لكن ان تفرح
لخساره منتخببك فهذا الامر استثنائيه
وبحاجه لتوقف عندك ايرانيون فرحوا جدا لبن
احتفلوا بخساره منتخب بلادهم وخروجه من
مونديال قطر وامام من امام المنتخب
الامريكي العدو اللدود للنظام الايراني
فبعد خساره المنتخب الايراني امام نظيره
الامريكيه في اخر مبارياته الموندياليه
شهد ايرانيون يحتفلون بهذه النتيجه في
مقاطع فيديو تم تداولها على نطاق واسع في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كهذه الصور التي
ستتابعها الان من العاصمه طاهره
[تصفيق]
ليس هذا فحدث بل وصلت ببعض المشجعين
الايرانيين الشامتين بخساره منتخب بلادهم
الى رفع العلم الامريكي اثناء الخروج
للاحتفال بالخساره في اصفهان
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ذلك صدى خساره المنتخب الايراني
والتشفي بخروجهم على يد المنتخب الامريكي
وصل الى مسقط راس الفتاه الكرديه مهسا
امينه التي اندلعت الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
الايرانيه عقبه مقتلها على يد ما تسمى
بشرطه الاخلاق وتظهر الصور اطلاق البعض
للالعاب الناريه احتفالا بالهدف الامريكي
في مرمى منتخب بلادهم
[موسيقى]
المناطق الكرديه الايرانيه خرجت للرقص
والاحتفال بالدبكات الكرديه الشعبيه كما
حصل في سلندر ومهابات في هذه الصور
فلتبعها
[موسيقى]
لو نهاري
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
اليابان تخطط لشراء 500 صاروخ توماهو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بينما تستمر المعارك على
جبهه بخمه تشرق اوكرانيا اعلن مصدر عسكري
للجارديان ان القوات الاوكرانيه تصدق
لمحاوله اقتحام للبلده نفذتها القوات
الروسيه قبل ان تفشل وتتراجع الى مواقعها
في ما اسقطت القوات الاوكرانيه ثلاث
طائرات استطلاع روسيه مسيره خلال ال 24
ساعه الماضيه بحسب الدفاع الاوكرانيه في
الشرق والجنوب والعاصمه
ومع تصاعد المخاوف من اطاله امد الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني تنام القلق بين الدول
المجاوره لروسيا ما دفع حلف شمال الاطلسي
الى محاوله تهدئه تلك البلدان وتضمنها عبر
زياده الدعم العسكري لها اتصيفعى وزراء
خارجيه الدول الاعضاء الى تهدئه مخاوف تلك
الدول المجاوره لروسيا التي تخشى طبعا ان
تزعزع موسكو استقرارها في ظل استمرار
الصراع في اوكرانيا الذي يؤثر على امدادات
الطاقه ويرفع الاسعار فيما تعاهد ينزتون
برج امين عام الحلف باجراء محادثه مع
مولدوفا وجورجيا والهرسك وهي الدول التي
تواجه ضغوط من موسكو كما اكد ان اعضاء
الناتو سيتخذون المزيد من الخطوات
لمساعدتها على حمايه استقلالها وتعزيز
قدرتها على الدفاع عن ارضها مشيت علينا ان
مصلحه الاطلسي تكمن في ضمان سلامه
[موسيقى]
نحو البحر الاسود يركز الناتو انظاره
واهتمامه والعوامل الدافعه لهذا الاهتمام
كثيره صيام الامنيه والجيسيه منها لتتحول
تلك البقعه المائيه الى بؤره التوتر لن
تنتهي اليوم او غدا ونظرا لحيويه هذا
البحر كثرت غايات ونوايا الدول المطله
وغير المطله كالولايات المتحده حول
التواجد على سواحل ومنافذ البحر الذي سمي
بالاسود كنايه عن الغيوم والسحب السوداء
التي تتجمع فوق هذا البحر وتنبع
استراتيجيه البحر الاسود بالنسبه
بقياده الولايات المتحده من قضيتين اولا
الالتزام بامن الحلفاء وفقه معاهده
الحلفاء اذ ان ثلاث دول اعضاء من اصل ست
تطل على البحر الاسود وهي تركيا
ورومانيا ثانيا تعتمد روسيا احد اكبر
الخصوم الجيوس السياسيين للولايات المتحده
على منطقه البحر الاسود في مجالات الطاقه
والتجاره والامن والاقتصاد ومن ثم لطالما
اعتبر تيمنتها على منطقه البحر الاسود
مساله بقاء وطني وتستخدم روسيا ايضا
قواعدها في البحر الاسود التي يقع كثير
منها في شبه جزيره القرم لشمله عمليات
عسكريه ابعد من اوكرانيا في سوريا مثلا
كما ان البحر الاسود يشكل اليوم ممرا هاما
وحيويا لشحن الحبوب من اوكرانيا الى
العالم وهو امر متعلق بالامن الغذائيه
العالميه ويتدفق الوقود من القوقاز واسيا
الوسطى الى اوروبا والعالم عبر البحر
الاسود ايضا وحوله اضافه الى رواسب
الهيدروكربونات الغنيه في البحر وعليه
مشاهدينا زاداته من وجود قواته في المنطقه
منذ عام 2014 كما انها اي قوات الناتو
تقوم بدوريات روتينيه في المنطقه بطائرات
مراقبه متقدمه لكن هذا ليس كافيا وفقا
لخبراء عسكريين امريكيين فعلى نيته ان يمد
رومانيا بصواريخ متطوره مضاده للسفن
والتفاوض بعد دول الواقعه على نهر الدانوب
بشان استخدام السفن الحربيه هناك لتحقيق
نوايا الحلف في البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
ومن البحر الاسود الى بحر اليابان التي
تدرس شراء ما يصل الى 500 صاروخ كروز
امريكيه الصنع من طراز توماهو بيحول عام
2028 بهدف تحسين قدرات الهجوم المضاد
وتواصل طوكيو اكبر تعزيز للاسلحه منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه في مواجهه التحديث
العسكريه
ومع اطلاق طبعا كوريا الشماليه عشرات
الصواريخ في اتجاهها هذا العام وتخطط
اليابان لمراجعه استراتيجيه على الامن
القومي وتوسيع مدى الصواريخ الارضيه لمنح
جيشها القدره على ضرب اهداف بعيده في
البحر
ضرب اهداف على مسافه تزيد عن 1000 كيلو
متر
[موسيقى]
اتجاه اليابان نحو تحديث جيشها وقدراتها
الدفاعيه سببه المخاوف من قدره الصين
المتناوله عسكريا او المتناميه عسكريا
بالاضافه الى انتهاكات كوريا الشماليه
وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه قالت ان قادفتين
صينيتين وما يشتبه انهما طائرتان حربيتان
روسيتان حلقت اليوم الاربعاء فوق بحر
اليابان واشارت الى ان القوات الدفاع
الجوي التابعه لها ارسل الطائرات المقاتله
ردا على ذلك بالتوازي امر جيش كوريا
الجنوبيه اليوم ايضا بالاقلاع الفوري
لطائرات مقاتله بعد الدخول طائرتين
حربيتين صينيتين وست طائرات حربيه روسيه
منطقه الدفاع الجوي لصال
[موسيقى]
اكدت مجموعه من الباحثين فاعليه الدواء
جديد لمرض الزهايمر بعد ما اكد التجربه
كلينيكيه انه يبطئ تدمير المرض للدماغ
ويخفض التدهور المعرفي لدى الماء المرضى
الذين يعانون من مراحل مبكره من المرض
ووفقا لشبكه بي بي سي البريطانيه فان هذا
الدواء الذي وصفه العلماء بالاختراق
العلمي ينهي عقودا من الفشل فيما يخص
ابتكار علاجات فعاله للالسايمر الدواء
الجديد الذي يدعى
يهاجم بروتين بيتا اميولويد الذي يتراكم
في ادمغه الاشخاص المصابين بمرض الالسايمر
واجر الباحثون تجربه كلينيكيه للدواء على
الفن
1995 متطوعا يعانون من المرض في مراحله
المبكره وتم اعطاء دفعات من الدواء الجديد
للمشاركين على مدار ثمانيه 18 شهرا ووجد
الفريق في الدراسه التي نشرت في مجله طبيه
ان الدواء ابطا تدمير المرض للدماغ
بالنسبه 27% وقال عدد من خبراء الصحه انه
على الرغم من ان التاثير يعد ايضا الى حد
ما فانه يوفر املا كبيرا في امكانيه علاج
المرض بشكل فعال في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
السعوديه النهارده تكسب وتفرحنا وتوقعت ان
شاء الله السعوديه 2-0 ان شاء الله
بتسويها السعودي
في مونديال قطر للعام 2022
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نعود مشاهدينا الى اجواء
المونديال وترقب العالم العربي لمباراه
المنتخب السعودي ومنتخب المكسيك والتي
يحتاج فيها الاخضر للفوز حتى يتاهل لدور
ال16 هلا اجواء في السعوديه وتوقعات
السعوديين نتبعها معا
باذن الله المباراه القادمه اللي هي
الليله ان شاء الله بتكون واحد صفر
للسعوديه باذن الله تعالى
وبسبب الروح اللي عندهم
اتوقع 2-1 لسه السعوديه
متوقع اثنين واحد للمنتخب السعودي
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله اتمنى الفوز للمنتخب السعودي
واحد صفر اليوم المباراه ان شاء الله
اثنين صفر بس الى حساسين لها سالم الدوسري
[موسيقى]
رصدنا ايضا مشاهدينا حاله التفاؤل التي
تعيشها الجماهير العربيه قبيل مواجهه
المنتخب السعودي بنظره المكسيكي ضمن
منافسات المجموعه الثالثه للصعود للدور
السادس عشر
ان شاء الله باذن الله السعوديه النهارده
تكسب وتفرحنا و نصعد ان شاء الله النتيجه
ان شاء الله تبقى واحد باذن الله السعوديه
فريق قوي جدا
وانا اصلا من محبين السعوديه فان شاء الله
ان هي تسعد النهارده
تجيب 2/0 ان شاء الله السعوديه يعني
تعملها بقى عشان المره اللي فاتت لعبه
ماتش كبير قوي بس يعني ما كانش في توفيق
لها فان شاء الله باذن الله النهارده
باذن الله تعالى ان شاء الله السعوديه
الموق الاخضر ما بيتوقف وان شاء الله تكون
رايته خفاقه والسعوديه قادره على الفوز
اذا مسك في المباراه ان شاء الله قدها
اثنين واحد اثنين واحد ان شاء الله كلنا
ثقه بصقور الاخضر وان شاء الله نتمنى لهم
الفوز وباذن الله بيت اهلي للدور 16 وباذن
الله يتاهل النهائيات ان شاء الله
ويجيبوا الفخر ما بس للسعوديه للعرب كامل
ان شاء الله
والان مشاهدينا الى شبكه مراسل العربيه من
الرياض نواف عزيز من الدوحه ليث بزاري من
القاهره احمد عثمان وسها جميل من عمان
سابدا معك ليس من الدوحه كيف هي الاجواء
قبيله انطلاق مباراه الاخضر والمكسيك
يعني الاجواء تشجيعيه بامتياز الجميع هنا
وصل الكثير من ما لا يجد مقاعد اصلا
والاماكن للاستراحه لمشاهده المباراه بعد
اقل من نصف ساعه نصف ساعه من الان
ليس انتقل من الدوحه الى الرياض ونواف
عزيز نواف كيف هي الاجواء التشجيعيه من
الرياض قبيله انطلاق المباراه
نعم هنا التفاؤل يملا المكان هنا في منطقه
فان فيستيفال التي تعتبر من مناطق موسم
الرياض ونظمتها هيئه الترفيه وحولت هذا
الملعب كما تشاهدون من خلف ملعب جامعه
الملك سعود الى منصه مشاهده كبرى للجماهير
يتوافد الان الاف الجماهير الى هذا الملعب
الى فان فيستيفال لمشاهده المباراه همم
كما نشاهد الان مدرجات بدات تمتلئ قبل
اكثر من ثلاث ساعات بدات الجماهير بالوصول
هنا
وايضا مع تخصيص شاشه كبيره
للمشاهده حقيقه التفاؤل وايضا التوتر بعد
الشيء لدى الجماهير هنا والحماس ايضا
لتاهل السعوديه الى دور السته عشر همم
بالفوز على المكسيك هنا الاجواء تنقل
الجماهير حقيقه
وكانهم في ملعب لوسيل في قطر حيث يلعب
المنتخب السعودي مع المكسيك جميع الاماكن
مهياه ستكون احتفالات كبيره في حال فوز
المنتخب وكما نعلم بعد ان فاز المنتخب في
المنافسه الاولى مع الارجنتين كان الملك
سلمان امر باجازه رسميه لطلبه المدارس
والجامعه وموظفي الحكومه وايضا القطاع
الخاص وايضا ولي العهد الامير محمد بن
سلمان انتشرت له صور وهو يحتفل احتفال
كبير بفوز المنتخب على همم الارجنتين في
هذه المره ايضا التفاؤل على الرغم من
الخساره امام هولندا لا يزال التفاؤل
قائما كون المنتخب السعودي قدم اداء علي
امام بولندا وفي هذه المنافسه التفاؤل
كبير ايضا
بالتاكيد هذه هذا المكان وهذا الملعب في
حال فوز السعوديه همم مع نهايه المباراه
وقبل البدء بدقائق سيتحول الى منصه كبيره
للاحتفالات همم من الجماهير التي تتواجد
هنا في همم منطقه فرانسيستيفال لمشاهده
المنافسات ومباراه السعوديه مع المكسيك
نواف يعني راح نتابع مع هذه الاجواء
الحماسيه من الرياض ساعود اليك طبعا بعد
قليل الان انتقل الى القاهره واحمد عثمان
احمد القاهره يعني احتفلت بقوه بالنصر
الاخير للاخضر بمباراه على الارجنتين كيف
هي الاجواء من هناك
نعم بالفعل هناك حاله كبيره جدا من
الحماسه قبل انطلاق المباراه يعني منذ
المباراه الاولى كنت اشاهدها في احد
المقاهي وكان في الشوط الثاني ربما حماسك
كبيره وكان الجمهور المصري يشجع المنتخب
المصري مع فوزه والدقائق الاخيره مع
الارجنتين وكانت هناك احتفالات في الشوارع
اليوم هناك ايضا امل كبير وريهان كبير من
الجماهير المصريه
من احد المقاهي في منطقه المهندسين خارج
هذا المقهى وفي الشوارع هناك من يبيعون
اعلام السعوديه وهناك الكثير من السيارات
التي اصطفت لشراء هذه الاعلام وهناك ربما
رهان كبير على نجاح المنتخب السعودي في
تجاوز المنتخب المكسيكي والتاهل يعني كان
هناك متابعه كبيره لمباراه هولندا كان
هناك تعاقد كبير مع الاداء الذي ادام قدمه
المنتخب السعودي وعدم نجاحه في الفوز
وربما هناك من يراهم بان
سنجح المنتخب السعودي في تجاوز المنتخب
المكسيكي اداء وفوزا والتاهل الى دور ال
من عندك احمد
سهى جميل من عمان سهى يعني عمان كما كل
المناطق
والمدن العربيه التي اليوم تتمنى ان تحتفل
بفوز الفريق العربي فريق السعوديه الاخضر
كيف هي الاجواء منه هناك
[موسيقى]
لا اعتقد ان الاجواء في الاردن تختلف عن
اي مدينه او دوله عربيه يبدو ان المنتخب
السعودي وحد الاردنيين ووحد العرب في هذا
المونديال على كلمه واحده وهو وهي
الامنيات بفوز المنتخب السعودي الاجواء
حماسيه خاصه همم قبل قليل فازت تونس على
فرنسا لكنها لم تتاهل للاسف الان الانبياء
اكثر بان تفوز السعوديه ويعني وتسجل فوزا
ونصرا تاريخيا كما يعني فازت على
الارجنتين ان تفوز اليوم على
المكسيك وتسجل هذا الفوز الجميع بانتظار
النتائج هذه المباراه الاجواء يعني الجميع
على اعصابه هذه الاجواء قبل بدايه
المباراه هناك في الاردن العديد من
المقاهي والعديد من الخيم التي فتحت
ابوابها لنقل المباراه خاصه هذه المباراه
ربما سيرين من خلف الاعلام السعوديه هناك
العديد من الانشقاق والمواطنين
قاء من الدوله من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومن الاردن ومن باقي المدن قدموا
الى هذه الخيمه لتسجيع المنتخب السعودي
هناك امنيات كبيره يعني تدفع الاردنيين
وتدفع العالم العربي للتوحد رياضيا نقي في
هذه اللحظه وجميع العرب يقفون على كلمه
واحده وهي الامنيات طبعا الجميع يعني
ينتظر المباراه على فارغ الصبر ربما هذه
الاجواء بسيطه بالنسبه لبدايه المباراه
يعني هذه الاجواء يعني تنقل لو قليلا من
همم حب همم العرب لان تسجل السعوديه هذا
النصر والامنيات تذهب ايضا لفوزها في
المونديال نحن ننتظر هذه المباراه على
فارغ الصبر والنتائج هذه المباراه التي
يتمنى الجميع فيها ان تسجل السعوديه نصرا
من جديد شكرا لك سهى ساعود اليك طبعا خلال
هذه التغطيه الان الى الدوحه مجددا ومفرد
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن اج
الاخضر قبيل الانطلاق المباراه يعني
الاجواء الحماسيه التي عاده ما عودنا
عليها جمهور المنتخب السعودي
بالفعل ليال كان هنالك تواجد كثيف لجمهور
الاخضر في محيط ملعب ستاد روسي للكثير
منهم دخلوا الى ملعب المباراه فعليه
استعدادا لانطلاقها بعد 20 دقيقه ولا زال
البعض في خارج الملعب يستعد للدخول
ومؤازره الاخضر في الحقيقه الكل قديمه من
كافه انحاء المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اليوم ويوم الامس كان هناك توافق كبير
الجمهور الاخضر الى الدوحه خصيصا لهذه
المباراه المصيريه والحاسمه
للسعوديه في ثالث مبارياتها في مجموعتها
في المونديال التقي ببعض الجمهور السعودي
الى الريال همم 20 دقيقه على بدايه
المباراه ما هي توقعاتكم امنياتكم لهذه
المباراه الاخيره والله شوف احنا كلنا
ثقاف الاخضر ان شاء الله اليوم ان شاء
الله الفائزين ان شاء الله اثنين واحد ان
شاء الله الاخبار ان شاء الله
السعوديه ان شاء الله ثلاثه واحد
سلطنه عمان
السعودي وان شاء الله موفقين اليوم
تعادل كبير بين الدول العربيه ودول الخليج
لمؤازره الاخضر هنالك ايضا شباب قدموا من
السعوديه خصوصا لهذه المباراه حدثنا من
اين اتيت وما هي امنياتك اليوم والله انا
جاي من الرياض ان شاء الله كلنا امل
بالرجال اللي موجودين باذن الله رغم النقص
لكن ان شاء الله انهم قدها وقدود ان شاء
الله ثقتنا فيهم كبيره باذن الله وانت
كمان والله انا سوداني اولا بس يعني دمي
سعودي فان شاء الله اليوم املنا خير في
المنتخب السعودي همم الدوسري ان شاء الله
هدفين والاثنين صفر وصاعدين ان شاء الله
تصير هداف سالم والله اهم شيء المنتخب
يصعد بعدين شوف اللي بعده
المنتخب
السعوديه والمنتخبات العربيه وان شاء الله
السعوديه هتطحنهم وهمم والناظر السعوديه
ان شاء الله من مصر وتحيا مصر وتحيا
السعوديه
شكرا ليال هناك ايضا بعض الجمهور الذي
يريد ان يشارك من اين اتيت وما هي
توقعاتكم امنياتك لمباراه
ان شاء الله المنتخب السعودي هيكسب
النهارده 0 - 2 ان شاء الله
المباراه ايضا من دول الخليج من اين اتيت
ان شاء الله اليوم نحنا مع الفريق السعودي
باذن الله
الله يعطيكم العافيه
جمهور عربي كثير جدا
لمؤازره الاخضر من مختلف
المنطقه العربيه والدول العربيه لمؤازره
الاخضر جنبا الى جنبي الى السعوديين الذين
يزحفوا بشكل كبير جدا وباعداد الى الدوحه
لمؤازره الاخضر اليوم في هذه المباراه
التي ستحدد همم ما اذا كان الاخضر سيستمر
في هذه البطوله الاسيه ما بعد الاداء
الكبيره الذي قدمه ااا ايضا كما تشاهدين
في الصوره هناك همم جنسيات مختلفه ليس فقط
من الدول العربيه ولكن ايضا كما شاهدتي
حقيقه الاخضر السعودي في هذه البطوله
عامله جو خاص بخصوصا بعد انتصار التاريخي
على الارجنتين جعلك كل الانبار تتجه الى
همم
وتتجه صوبه
لمشاهده
المستويات التي يقدمها مبارياته بشكل
العام
ومع الزملاء اجواء قبيل همم هذه المباراه
ولكن ساعود الى الرياض
والزميل نواف عزيز نواف كيف هي الصوره من
هناك يعني ما الذي رصدته بشوارع الرياض
كيف هي التحضيرات خصوصا انه الامل كبير
اليوم بان يحقق الاخضر ناصر جديد بهذا
الممتعال
[موسيقى]
نعم هنا التواجد الاكبر في شوارع الرياضه
الجهات الحكوميه وفرت العديد من مناطق
المشاهده في الحدائق وحول المقاهي وايضا
في المسارات الرياضيه اضافه الى ان وزاره
الرياضه وفرت اماكن كبيره وخصصتها لمشاهده
مباريات كاس العالم وخاصه مباريات المنتخب
السعودي هناك ما تشاهدين الحضور للعائلات
كبير وهنا تتواجد ايضا العديد من الاغاني
الوطنيه والاحتفالات في هذا المكان ربما
للتخفيف ايضا وهي تساعد على تخفيف توتر
الجماهير قبل دقائق من بدء المباراه
نستطلع الان اراء بعض المتواجدين هنا اهلا
بك همم توقعاتك للمباراه
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله خير
متحمس جدا طيب اهلا وسهلا فيك اسمك هو
توقعك اسمي مؤيد السلطان وان شاء الله
باذن الله حنا متفائلين من الفوز وان شاء
الله نقول الفوز لنوفاق شاص جديده
[موسيقى]
الالاف
والتواجد ايضا لمشاهده المباريات
والمؤازره المنتخب
في امام المكسيك سنبقى معك طبعا نتابع
صوره من هناك نواف اعود الى
ليث ليث لم يجهز بعد اعود الى عبد المحسن
عبد المحسن يعني ما زالت ما زال المشجعين
والحاضرين يتوافدون الى الملعب كيف هي
صوره من هناك
جدا ربما 10 دقائق اكثر همم بقليل جدا من
بدء المباراه الا ان الاعداد لا زالت
تتواجد بشكل كبير كما تشاهدين هذه احد
مدخل الجماهير همم العداد لا زال تدخل
بكثافه الى داخل الملعب الملعب الذي
يحتضمن اكثر من 85,000 متفرج ربما تكون
هذه المباراه من اكثر المباريات في كاس
العالم حضورا في هذه المباراه نظرا للزخم
الكبير الذي شاهدناه في الخارج والتواجد
الجماهيري الكبير المختلف الجنسيات سواء
كان السعوديه وحتى الميكسيكيه او حتى
العربيه والخليجيه المتواجده لموازره
الاخضر في هذه المباراه اذا التوقعات بان
يكون عدد الحضور الجماهيري الكبير جدا
ايضا شاهدت اعداد كبيره جدا ليال في محيط
الملعب لا تملك تذاكر تبحث عن تذاكر في
هذه المنطقه على الرغم من انها همم الذين
لديهم تذاكر هم العدد الاكبر وهم الذي
يملؤون
بالعب ولكن هنالك اعداد ضخمه جدا همم لن
همم يتسنى لهم دخول همم في هذه المباراه
نظرا لعدم توفر همم تذاكر همم في هذه
اللحظات وانا اشاهد واحد من الجماهير الذي
كان يبحث عن تذكره قبل قليل
وربما حلفه الحظ لكي انت حصلت تذكره
يحتفل كما تشاهدين ان شاء الله يحتفل كما
شاهدتها
الكثير من الجمهور الذي يبحث عن تذكره همم
[موسيقى]
ههه هذه احتماليه خاصه لحضور المباراه
والحصول على التذكره الريال هذا هو الوطن
العربي
هذه المباراه شكرا لشبكه مراسلين العربيه
من الرياض نواف عزيز من الدوحه ليس بصاري
وعبد المحسن الحربي ومن القاهره احمد
عثمان جميل من عمان شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
كان عارف مجموعتنا صعبه في كاس العالم فما
حد متوقع مننا حتى نتعادل او نفوز في اللي
بيقولوا لكم فقط خليكم مرتاحين العبوا
لعبكم وهمم واستمتعوا في البطوله المجموعه
صعبه فيها من اقوى فرق العالم ما هو متوقع
فوز او تعادل اللي نبغى منكم تلعبون لعبكم
المريح اللي يؤدي وان شاء الله القادم
افضل انا ما ابغى اي احد يكون تحت ضغط
نفسي يمكن يؤثر حتى على همم اداؤكم همم
الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
في البيت السعودي الذي يعاد ملتقى مشجعين
منتخب السعودي من كافه الجنسيات يعد هذا
المكان
في الدوحه ومركز لنقل الثقافه السعوديه
لضيوف المونديال
[موسيقى]
احتفالات على وقع الخساره العاب ناريه
وهذيج في المدن الايرانيه بعد هزيمه
منتخبهم امام الولايات المتحده
لسه خالص
البحر الاسود
اختراق علمي دواء شديد لمرضى الزهايمر
يمنح املا بامكانيه علاج المصابين والقضاء
على المرض
التاسعه انتهت واخبار العربيه مستمره كما
كليله الان الى 360 وزميل طاهر طاهر يعني
طبعا سنبقى نتابع معك مجريات انطلاق
المباراه بين المنتخب السعودي
والمكسيك بكل تاكيد يعني لما تطلع من
الاستوديو هتشوفي جو المحطه كيف في الخارج
وفي الداخل وهذا يعطيني ان انقل لك ماذا
لدي اليوم لانه ليس لدينا شيء اخر
[ضحك]
ههه